alena in New York says I love my husband
and I want to overcome our issue around
money however my husband lacks the
ability or desire to change spending
habits that affect me too he says he
wants to change says he's going to
change but it's always next week or next
month I can't handle the constant roller
coaster help please is there any hope
for us it's killing our marriage if we
changed the subject from money to
alcoholism or drug use it would sound
exactly the same I love my husband and
and I want to overcome our issues around
his use of illegal drugs however my
husband lacks the ability or desire to
change his habits and they affect me too
says he wants to change gun change but
it's always next week or next month I
can't handle it
put yourself is there any hope for us
it's killing our marriage so it says
it's a misbehavior as what it amounts to
in this case thank God it's not drug use
or alcoholism which is much more
difficult to overcome than simple
immaturity which is what this is the
inability to control impulses is
attributed to children children do what
feels good I can't control my impulses
people like me just buy stuff people
like you were children it's a childish
behavior the inability to engage in
basic self control is childish it is
what children do there are a lot of
emotional children walking around in
adult sized bodies I get that sometimes
I'm that guy sometimes I do you know I
want a chocolate chip cookie shut up you
know and I you know the inability to
control that impulse but self-control is
an attribute
being able to delay pleasure for a
greater good is an attribute of
adulthood so any of us when we cave to
our childish impulses rather than do
what's good for the long term for
ourselves and those that we love you
know all of us do that the problem is
when you do it more than you do the
adult stuff adult stuff is a plan and
follow what children do what feels good
and so what's important for all of us is
to do more adult stuff than childish
stuff so we get to be an adult but when
you are more childish than you are adult
then your spouse writes me an email and
says it's killing our marriage because
I'm married to a little boy a little boy
who cannot control his spending you know
I mean that's what that's what she's
saying and it's like yeah man
dude come on you would man up your
little woman is calling you a boy child
seriously so how do you fix that that's
not a financial problem that's a
maturity problem one definition of
maturity is the ability to delay
pleasure learning to delay pleasure live
like no one else so that later we can
live and give like no one else you don't
accidentally win and so it's about that
this is about maturity it's about
growing up and it's about him putting
the good of his family the good of his
relationship with his wife ahead of his
own selfish little childish impulses
he's selfish that's the problem we all
are sometimes I'm the same way sometimes
I do sharing exactly the same way no she
doesn't me the same way you know me we
all do this stuff the question is at
what percentage and the lower my
percentage of stupid childish impulses
the higher percentage or the higher
quality of life I have
I mean I meet people they impulse a
Porsche you know you can impulse an
f-150 that'll kill you man
I'll kill you you cannot impulse that
stuff these this is a major decision
when you're spending money like this so
the answer to your question Alena is
that you should go and see a marriage
counselor you ought to ask him to come
with you because I'm afraid your
marriage is gonna end
if he doesn't grow up because you're
tired of living with a little boy this
the wording in your email submission is
dripping with anger due to frustration I
don't really blame you but the problem
with that is you're gonna reach a point
that the switch is gonna flip and you're
done and there's not gonna be any
getting you back into the deal when
people switch flips particularly ladies
I've watched it happen for 30 years
where the marriage is struggling and I'm
doing financial coaching and she's just
hanging on and hanging hanging on
hanging on hanging on hanging on hanging
on can't believe she's hung on this long
and then I'm thinking man that maybe
this old boys gonna turn around and
hanging on and hanging on
boom she's done all of a sudden the
switch just like a light switch
it just goes to off and no marriage
counselor no pastor no friend no parent
can talk her into coming back she's done
baked turkey man I mean it's over and so
you don't want you to be that Halina you
want to catch this before you get closer
to the switch then you realize you are
and that means you guys need some
marital help big time you need a
marriage counselor and go see your
pastor find out if they do marriage
counseling at your church get a good
Christian marriage counselor to walk you
through this and talk to you talk to you
about relationships and spiritual things
and him and if he won't go at least you
can go to
learn how to talk to him to get him to
go because you guys are gonna have to
get on the same page this guy
something's got to shake him and he's
got to grow up because you are married
to a boy child we have a manhood crisis
in this culture there's a shortage
there's some males in the culture but
there's a manhood shortage and there's
an adulthood shortage in general a lot
of people walking around that somehow
their emotional growth was stunted and
they never really came all the way into
adulthood for whatever reason and we can
see that by their childish impulsive
selfish misbehavior again I've done it
too I'm not saying them any better I'm
not being condescending so those of you
think I'm condescending that's just
because you are being convicted by this
very little rant right here I'm not
condescending at all I've done every bit
of this I've done I've been more
immature and more impulsive and more
stupid than all of you but when I quit
doing it to the extent I quit doing it
the quality of my life goes up the
quality of my relationships go up the
results I get in the marketplace go up
when I manage my emotions instead of
them managing me and it keeps me from
being impulsive because I'm angry or
impulsive because I'm scared or
impulsive because I'm just four years
old down inside when I manage that and
it's called self control it is the
attribute of an adult I get a better
life and that's how I've gotten a better
life and that's why I'm a better grandpa
than I was
a daddy
and by the way that's a rule you have to
be a better grandpa than you were a
daddy because you should have learned
something through all those years my
gosh you didn't learn anything what are
you just stupid
Papa Dave ought to be better at this
than he was when he was thirty right
same thing with your money same thing
with your career
same thing with the whole deal all your
relationships right it's called growing
up that's what it's about whether it
whether it's adult inge what the
Millennials call it right adulting
that's what we're talking about here